Brans use cloud to reach out to the influencers for word of mass marketing . So
for example Audi has this test drive combined and they are offered to
influencers in San Francisco. They basically invited all those opinion leaders
in different vectors of the industry to come in and test drive one of this
newest model, and get a sense of how they feel about this new model. That's what
Albie did, and Virgin America for example offered this VIP servers for those,
who are even just account user, when they come to the airport terminals, the
envidos influences over to their VIP lounge, just for all the pros they have
there. Because you know, they think having a car score is a good indicator of
you being. Influentia Savio was this social media thing that's coming up. So,
and people has different ways of using car scores across different domains. I've
also heard of some dating sites using cars score as a signal to match people up.
>> Come on, the other ways that you can think of often top of your head. >> Some
CM malls chip marking offers is Klout to just filter their candidates with.
Because a lot of the bigger, more traditional companies, when they try to adapt
to their social media era, they're trying to hire someone with social media
background. To be able to help with their branding and, and, and the picture of
their company. And for those jobs having a Klout is a must. I've heard. I think
Barrack Obama, the President, has the highest class score of 99. And San
Francisco Giants since just recently after they won the World's Series, they had
a share that same score for a month. >> Wow, and Justin Bieber? >> Justin Bieber
has a very high class score of 92. And a lot of celebrities and media
celebrities are a whiz in their range. And but he's one of, definitely one of
the highest Klout score.